♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE TOLD YOU WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO ASSESS WHETHER
WEST WAS CRAZY AS VIRTUALLY
EVERY SINGLE MEDIA OUTLET ON
PLANET EARTH CLAIMS EVERY DAY,
ALL YEAR LONG.
IS HE CRAZY?
AS YOU TRY TO ASSESS THAT, ASK
IS WHAT YOU JUST HEARD OVER THE
PAST 40 MINUTES ANY CRAZIER THAN
WHAT YOU SEE ON TELEVISION EVERY
DAY?
OF THE LIES, THE LUNACY
PRESENTED TO YOU WITH A STRAIGHT
FACE AS REALITY -- IS NOT CRAZY
AT ALL.
HE'S A BIG THINKER.
WE ASKED HIM ABOUT 2020 FOR WHAT
HE PLANS TO DO AND ALSO ABOUT
ELON MUSK -- HERE IT IS.
>> PEOPLE WITH POWER TRY TO MAKE
OTHER PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY.
MY POWER IS THROUGH GOD.
IF SOMEONE EVER SAYS ANYTHING
LIKE YOU DID A GREAT JOB, PRAISE
GOD.
ATHEISTS LOVE THE TERM
NARCISSIST, WHEN YOU BELIEVE IN
YOURSELF, THEY SAY IT'S
NARCISSISTIC.
I LOVE THE DYNAMIC OF HOW YOU
COMPARE, YOU SHOW THAT THERE IS
STILL HUMANITY EVEN WITH THE
POSITION GOD HAS PLACED ME IN.
WHY DID MOSES SMITE THE ROCK,
WHY DID HE GET THAT FRUSTRATED?
AND JUST TO BE ABLE TO BE
GENTLE, TO BE MORE GENTLE -- GOD
IS ALIVE -- LOOK AT THIS RIGHT
HERE.
LOOK HOW QUIET IT IS RIGHT NOW,
THAT'S GOD, GOD IS OF ORDER, THE
DEVIL'S OF CHAOS.
>> Tucker: THAT IS TRUE.
>> I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MY
POTENTIAL RUN FOR 2024 AND
TRUMP'S POTENTIAL RUN AND THE
BELOVED RON DeSANTIS POTENTIAL
RUN FOR 2024, MAYOR SUAREZ,
POTENTIAL RUN FOR 2024.
THEY THOUGHT TRUMP WAS A JOKE.
FOR OLDER WHITE PEOPLE QUICK TO
CLASSIFY A BLACK PERSON ONLY BY
THE FACT THAT WE ARE BLACK.
EVEN TRUMP A PERSON WE CONSIDER
TO BE A FRIEND OF MINE WHEN I
WENT TO THE WHITE HOUSE, I
CALLED HIM AFTER THAT TO GET
AESOP ROCKY OUT OF JAIL.
ONE OF THE THINGS HE SAID TO ME
YOU'RE MY FRIEND WHEN YOU CAME
TO THE WHITE HOUSE MY BLACK
APPROVAL RATING WENT UP 40%.
AND FOR POLITICIANS, ALL BLACK
PEOPLE ARE WORTH IS AN APPROVAL
RATING.
THE DEMOCRATS FEEL THEY DON'T
OWE US ANYTHING AND REPUBLICANS
FEEL THEY DON'T OWE US ANYTHING.
BLACKS HAVE NEVER DEMANDED
SOMETHING FOR OUR VOTE AND
THAT'S SOMETHING I TALKED TO
ICE CUBE ABOUT.
WHAT ARE WE ASKING FOR, HOW DO
WE CHANGE OUR LIVES?
IF ALL OF OUR ORGANIZATIONS AND
OUR COLLEGES AND EVEN OUR TITLE
WAS MADE BY WHITE PEOPLE, ALL OF
OUR JOBS.
BLACK WALL STREET, HARLEM AFTER
GENTRIFICATION, THERE'S NEVER
BEEN A FULLY BLACK OWNED
COMMUNITY WHERE WE HAVE ALL THE
MUNICIPALITIES -- WE NEED THAT.
90% OF AMERICA IS NOT EVEN
DEVELOPED.
I'M NOT ONE OF THE PEOPLE THAT
GO UP AND SAY I WANT TO STOP
ANYBODY FROM MAKING MONEY.
THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE MONEY AND
THE POWERS THAT BE, I AM YOUR
TRUE NIKOLA TESLA AND I'M NOT
EVEN A SCIENTIST.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU THINK OF
ELON MUSK, DO YOU KNOW HIM?
>> VERY WELL.
>> Tucker: WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON
HIM?
>> YOU SAID THAT BECAUSE I SAID
TESLA?
>> Tucker: FIRST THING THAT
POPPED --
>> EVE